what are we going to do the first part
of the lecture today I prepare a couple
of games of the world champion Bobby
Fischer games us world champion so we'll
take a look at the games these are very
short games that he managed to win in
the you know 15 moves maybe just against
strong opponents just very nice
miniatures so we'll take a look at three
of his games and after that we're going
to work on some tactics the second part
of our lecture ok so I want to make sure
everybody can see the screen here and so
so we will start the first game I have
it's the game played between Fisher and
another u.s. Grandmaster Reshevsky in
1958 and this was a very nice game so I
like to show you the first and ask you
some questions see if you can find the
moves ok so Fisher is playing with the
white pieces efore c5 so what's the name
of this opening Sicilian defense
absolutely this is the one of the most
popular openings nowadays and in fact
it's been very popular for a long time
one of the strongest defenses against
efore so it's a Sicilian defense when
you play E for opponent plays c5
immediately we know that this is the
Sicilian defense there are many
different lines the lines they can play
against but the opening is Sicilian
defense so Fischer played 93 96 the idea
of the Sicilian defense he wants to just
fight for this d4 square if white wants
to get an advantage he needs to play d4
to try to control the square so he takes
90 x d4 g6 black is trying to fianchetto
the bishop on g7 so Knight c3 played
Bishop g7
we should be 3:9 f6 Bishop c4 and here
black castled we should be three and
black play the Knight a5 move first
question is it a good idea to put the
knight on a five okay let's see but you
have to tell me why it's not a good idea
to put tonight and here we see even a
strong grandmaster like Reshevsky he
puts the knight on the side of the board
and he's going to be in big trouble
basically after this one he is losing so
why it's not a good idea to put the
knight on the side of the board yes you
put what well when you put the knight on
the side of the board very good good
let's course to go to so you can only go
to four squares okay so see this is the
possible scores you can go to with a
knight but if you bring the baton Knight
back on c6 how many squares you can go
to from here eight right so that's why
you don't want to put the knight on the
side of the board sometimes you can do
that but in this scheme he played 95 and
this is a bad move here now you need to
find a strong move for Fischer white to
play so think about it a little bit for
a few minutes before you raise your hand
so Knight moves away from the center
that means he is no longer controlling
some important squares so what can you
take advantage of that now one mistake
and now black is losing think about it
try to see what the night was doing on
c6 that when he moved away he's no
longer controlling which square yes
first move
well you could go Bishop to a4 but but
then he actually now brings the knight
in so you have you need a really strong
move here it's not just a regular move
you make you actually you need to play
attacking move here and to be able to
get a big advantage so it's a strong
attacking move it's not just a regular
move like castle or something you need
to find something stronger see the
knight was on c6 he moved from c6 to a5
see ok yes
'if I've very good you play e5 now now
you're attacking the knight now he needs
to move the knight because if he takes
on b3 White has a very strong move here
instead of just capturing the knight
back he takes the other night so this is
an in-between move instead of just
capturing back he takes the other night
yes
aha and now you don't take tonight you
take the bishop again now you're
attacking his rook so he takes back and
after you take the knight you will end
up with two minor pieces for a rook so
to mine the pieces what's the value of
two minor piece okay but raise your hand
yeah okay if you know it just raise your
hand yes well each hits three points so
it's six right okay now black also has
six pounds because he has a rook and
upon but in this kind of positions it's
it's better to have the minor pieces
because you have good attacking chances
it's like you have two pieces attacking
and he's going to have only one rope
defending so it's it's better to have
the minor pieces yes three major pieces
yes yes three major pieces but this
would be better for white disposition
because of the minor pieces and the
possibilities to attack okay because as
you can see black King it doesn't have
that many defenders here and his dark
squares are also weak so for example you
can this is a one way to start the
attack Queen c1 and immediately you're
threatening to kobish wait six check
okay so his dark squares are weak so
that's why after he played e5 black
decided that if he takes from between
his just he's in trouble so he went
ninety eight and now
very nice tactical idea this is a pretty
advanced tactic here but I want to do
something that is me a little bit more
difficult so you can see white to play
and win again as you can see one night
is on the side of the board another
night is back and no connection between
the pieces so this is very bad for black
now but you need to find the strong move
to actually take it down to chew it it's
that one move it's like you have to
calculate a few moves maybe two moves -
three moves so he hears that development
the knight is also on the side of the
board what can you do
oh okay yes go ahead here yeah well but
but he could take your bishop here so
you have to do something quick here
because you know if you don't do
something quickly we'll take your lights
go bishop so that's why he wants to take
your lights go bishop here so that's how
you have to do something immediately
here because if it takes the bishop then
you cannot attack yes
you move the bishop we're here well you
could move yeah you can move the bishop
here but again this is just a normal
move yeah so how about the sacrifice who
can find the sacrifice you can do with
the bishop here well again it's just not
the sacrifice you have to see it yes
here excellent okay Bishop s and this is
what Fisher played for a moment it looks
like a bad move because he can just take
the piece and we know the value of the
piece is three pounds and pawn is just
one pawn so let's see why he played this
move so now if he takes with the rook
takes Bishop can you see the winning
move now
after which you winning the Queen after
which you winning the black Queen here
okay you mean II six you could do that
but you have something much stronger win
the Queen in order to win the Queen you
need to attack the Queen first and the
idea involved here is called discovery
discovery attack yes very good
Knight to e6 attacking the Queen and
let's take a look where the Queen can go
to see the knight is blocking the Queen
also the pawns and the bishop so he has
only few squares if it goes here we just
take it with a knight and this square is
controlled by the bishop so now the only
thing he can do is to take but when he
takes we simply take the Queen so the
idea was when you sacrifice the bishop
you get the control of these six square
and now you have this very nice
ninety-six move and the Queen is trapped
now let's take a look now what's going
to happen if he takes to the king
because he can also do that he can take
with a king in this line you're actually
going to be able to checkmate him now so
what's the first move here to draw his
king forward yes if you do Queen Utley
right away he can go back okay so you
need to do something else first to make
sure his king is coming to the center
yes again same thing with you go pawn to
e6 he just goes back to GA so try to
maybe sacrifice something else
to make sure his king is coming forward
not going back to jail because if his
King goes back here then it's going to
be safe okay yes absolutely yes
96 again same idea he cannot take with
the pawn again because you take the
Queen so he has to take with the king
now when opponent king is coming to the
center of the board with a lot of pieces
it's always very dangerous so you have
good attacking chances okay okay he
could go back but then you just take the
Queen okay because remember you are
attacking the Queen so if it goes back
you take the Queen the most valuable
piece and then you should win the game
well but which one is better rook or
queen okay so all let's try to take the
model the most valuable piece okay now
let's see who can find a mate here next
move what should be our next move here
to make sure we have a good attack yes
excellent check you're getting very
close now the only move he has is to go
quick to f5 he cannot take because the
knight is protecting so he goes King f5
and now
what can you do here yes you could go
Queenie for but he can just go back to
his six okay try to try to try to use
another picture try to use another piece
that you can bring into the game here
you also have a discovery check ideas -
yes
aha pawn to g4 okay
pawn to g4 is good idea to check now he
captures now which piece you want to
bring into the game
rook right so we go rook g1 check now if
you place if he goes back to a5
checkmate in 1 you could move the pawn
that's probably winning but then he will
block with the bishop so you have
something in one move here one move
checkmate yes well but Queen - before I
go back to e6 see Queen check I go back
Queen check I go back you have something
stronger here excellent
rook to g5 checkmate see even though
black is more material here but you
Singh is in trouble
that's why interests it's very important
the safety of the King you could be up
lots of material but you will get
checkmated here and if he doesn't go
back to f5 let's say he tries to play
this move now what do you do here -
checkmate here
same move check if it goes here now use
the Queen right check he goes here
checkmate in two now many different ways
how to checkmate here in two months yes
rook g3 check King takes h2 and now and
now let's see okay very good Queen to
cheat you there are many ways to
checkmate here but because the king like
this when you have so many pieces
attacking that you will find a checkmate
so it's just you know you just need to
calculate but there are many ways to win
a pawn in this position you want to push
this it this is probably also winning
but I think he will just go Bishop e5
but then we have to play g4 again so
this this is also winning but you know
you can just go g4 right away okay so
this was the first game okay that we
went again Fischer was white against
Grandmaster Reshevsky questions
here okay yeah
so I yeah we we can check me right away
we need to bring some more pieces so we
play g4 here so we can bring our rook
into the game with the check then with
the bishop queen and rook then we can
checkmate them so always try to bring
some more pieces when you're attacking
somebody and you see cannot checkmate
right away you try to see which piece
you can bring into the game and try to
do that with the check okay it's very
important
all right next game is a very quick win
actually in 10 moves actually 10 moves
Fischer won in 1963 against a very good
player actually Reuben fine so let's
take a look at this game okay so Fischer
always played efore so if you studied if
you study some of his games you always
open up the game with before this was
his favorite move and it was a very
attacking player you know but he had
some great positional games as well but
he would like to attack so II for a 5 9
f3 d6 this is considered not the best
respond in this position for black
because it's it's bit passive it blocks
the bishop and this is like a Philidor
defense so the best move in this
position is to play 96 to go through
Lopes or Knight f6 the Russian game so
these two moves are better because when
you play d6 you like you commit too soon
it's just more of like a defective
opening here so it's a slightly worse at
least so I play d6 and of course Fischer
immediately try to play active d4 trying
to control the center 97 you will see
that immediately black is just trying to
defend yes
yeah yeah let's get to the crucial point
let's get to the crucial point because
I'm just just going to show you the few
opening moves first it's so castles
Bishop e7 now he took Turk he developed
this queen here
so you can put the rope on open pass
always remember when you see an open
file and you have a rook you want to put
the rook on open file open file is when
there is a file like this and there are
no puns on that file that's the open
file if there is let's say one pawn on
the file what is it called okay good
half semi up and file or half open file
ok ok so now queen eat we played now
Knight gf6 rook t1 who can tell me
what's the idea behind this last move
why he played rugby one what is white
threatening his last move was rook t1
yes
if he does what sorry I couldn't hear
you
well he brought the rukon open file and
this is what is the rook go into the
Quinn what do we call this in chess what
do we call this
ah-huh if it moves the knight we take
the Queen right so this Knight is called
the pinned piece okay
it's called pinned piece okay and there
are two different the pins we have we
have one pin that is called absolute pin
when the piece is pinned to the king
that's absolutely because the piece
absolutely cannot move so that's
absolute pin and who knows what kind of
pin is this it's not absolute pin yes
yes so this is called relative pin okay
so two pins remember absolute pin when a
pin piece is pin to the king and we have
a relative pin now what is white
threatening here
excellent now for example if black just
cancels since the piece is pinned that
means this piece is actually it looks
like it's defending but it's not really
defending it because it's pinned so you
just simply take the piece and if it
takes back we take the Queen okay so
when you take the Queen this will be I
mean you're you're up lots of material
now so your threat is to take ninety
five so Reuben fine plate Queen c7 a
logical move moving away from the pin
right it's good to do that but in fact
now he's losing let's see if we can find
a three move combination now three move
actually he resigned in two moves but he
saw that the tournament was coming and
he resigned so let's see white to play
and win here you have to play very
energetically and try to find a way to
win let's see
think about it for a little bit don't
rush spend minute or two and then raise
your hand you have to calculate not just
one move you have to try to see three
moves
what did Fisher play here on
yes you could play bishop play f7 but
then I just take and you still have some
ideas here but you have something better
than that okay you have something better
than that here which piece we can try to
activate here and attack we usually try
you know to develop all our pieces to
attack but this is an exception at this
point we can leave this pieces here and
just try to attack because we have a
winning continuation here so which piece
you can activate here immediately
yes Bishop which Bishop this Bishop
where where do you wanna
because somebody already suggested this
move and it's bit too early we need to
do something first okay we need to do
something first
yes but look to the seven he just takes
no he just takes and then we we lose
some material because the value of the
rook is five and the minor piece Knight
is valued only three pawns sometimes we
can do that but if we have a really
strong follow-up yes go back but this
piece is a very always remember when you
have d3 yeah but this piece is already
developed in the opening try not to move
the same piece more than once because
that's you're wasting time okay
try to attack or develop the rest of the
pieces here if let's say we didn't have
attacking a move the best move would
have been to develop the knight or the
bishop but definitely don't want to go
back okay so now what do you do here
attacking move here you need to attack
something and increase the pressure yes
Queen d3 mmm better you're putting
pressure here but you know this is
protected he will just castle yes nine
to g5 attacking on f7 now one to two
piece is attacking only the King is
defending in here so the only way for
him to defend is to castle okay so he
just canceled now he defended this it
looks like he defended it but now why to
play and win two moves you have to see
two moves now
okay just just raise your hand yeah okay
yes here a little bit better a little
bit better because if you put the bishop
there I don't have to take I don't have
to take you have something more forcing
here
Bishop f7 very good check now he has to
take because if it doesn't take then
he's lost the pawn and after 96 fork
he's going to lose some material okay so
remember when you're attacking two
pieces at the same time that is a fork
so when you bring the knight here
attacking the Queen and rook that's a
fork yeah Knights are very powerful so
he has to take by the way
Fischer's opponent Reuben fine resigned
here hand moves only he resigned but why
if it takes now what's the winning move
what is the winning move here
what is the winning move here
okay take care you could do that but
then he will take you back okay you
could take you could take he takes but
something better here before you take
that can you find a way to increase the
pressure increase the pressure okay can
you do that yes here Queenie try if you
can he will take you when hyp will take
you yes very good move Quincey for
activating the Queen and now he's got
two pieces attacking on f7 and black
cannot defend okay
the only thing he can try to do here is
to play 95 and now I have a question for
you here do you want to take the night
or something else you want to do first
before you take the night okay yeah go
ahead go ahead
very good because if you take this night
he actually can take your night and he's
not losing his rook anymore okay so
that's why you always try to take a more
valuable piece first in this position so
you take the rook and now he takes back
and then only we take and white is up a
exchange and upon and just winning yeah
some discovery tricks coming up - okay
good so again the combination was takes
takes if he goes away 96 wins exchange
on top of the pawn so it's just white is
winning and if it takes with the rook we
just go here and winning the game okay
good job
okay so this was another game played by
Fisher
now actually I want to move on now do
couple a couple of tactical exercises
okay the idea we're going to work on
today it's a double attack okay so you
make one move and then you're at least
attacking two pieces at the same time
okay so think about it first what can
you do here always try to find a piece
that is not protected right here there
there is a piece first tell me which
piece is not protected for black which
piece is not protected find the
unprotected piece yes rock is
unprotected okay so you need to find a
way to attack the rook and at the same
time attack something else
because that will be a fork okay good we
have a lot of hands that's good and you
always have to look at the entire board
okay to be able to find a good move okay
yes the best move here
you move the Queen to g5 that's the
correct move because now you are
attacking first of all you're attacking
the pawn on g7 and if you take this pawn
it's going to be a checkmate you're also
tacking the rope correct
what else you're attacking what else
uh-huh and again we see a knight on the
side of the board
see that's why I remember it's not a
good idea to put a knight on the side of
the board because again an example where
it could be a problem
knight on the side of the board so Queen
g5 and black or white he's already
winning because you just have so many
threats the knight is hanging g7 and the
rook okay so this is called double
attack yesh yeah
you could go to f6 but then look at my
bishop Bishop takes it okay okay now
let's see why to play and find the
double attack remember we are just doing
double attacks today so you need to find
all the type of double attack moves here
for white
just put the session
so trying to see which two two things
you can try to attack here in one move
because you're going to be able to win a
piece if you do that okay raise your
hand if you think you have the move so
you look at your bishop you have to see
what is that you have a bishop here and
the bishop is attacking here so that's a
very important pawn that you're
attacking here try to see a connection
here that you can make a move and attack
two things at once here
you make one move you attack two things
at once okay Queen to h5 you are only
tagging one thing you're threatening
checkmate right but it's not a double
attack it's just a single attack yeah I
just go here and I stop that idea okay
double attack is when you're attacking
two things yeah so what can you do not
Queen h5 here you need to do something
better here yes here but that just
attacks the Queen right no well the pawn
is already attacked pawn is already
attack so it's it really only attacks
the Queen and I just move my queen
try to find something better it's a nice
little move you make and suddenly you
win a piece or your checkmate
yes
you're close but not Queen a5 Queen a5 I
can take
yeah but then Bishop takes it's just
going to be an exchange here something
better you have here something better
okay Queenie 4 correct you move the
Queen up to e4 why is this a double
attack
go ahead why is this a double attack
attacks the bishop because now we
increase the pressure on the bishop we
have two pieces attacking and checkmate
that's why this is a double attack very
strong technical idea if you remember
and know how to use this you can win a
lot of games double attack you move the
Queen up to one square attacking the
bishop twice and also threatening
checkmate if it makes a move to defend
it what do you do checkmate into
checkmate into now let's see yes
here you have to take something what can
you take with the Queen pink aha you go
bond check he cannot take back because
the bishop is guarding it he has to go
back to f8 and now if the king is on f8
what do you do
Queen H a checkmate okay so very
important here so you play the move
Queen efore nice move double attack
attacking the bishop
and on h7 okay yes which one this one
yeah but this one is protected if it's
something protected you're not really
attacking I mean you attack when you
like threatening to take okay so so this
move is queenie for remember double
attack okay now we're going to do one
more double attack idea okay okay why to
play and find the double attack in two
moves okay this is a little bit
different a little bit more difficult
because in the previous positions we did
you had a double attack right away here
you don't have one immediately you need
to find you need to create one actually
so think about it first try to see the
pieces you need to double attack and
then think of an idea how can you do
that double attack you know okay go
ahead
very good first we go Queen e5 check he
has to go here
but if you go up to ei you cannot you're
going to miss kit tweet that's going to
be taken now absolutely very good that
was excellent yeah Queen d5 good okay
you got another one okay but how is that
going to do a double attack double
attack remember we're trying to do is
idea that we attack two pieces at the
same time okay so it's really only one
way to do so we go check first we
improve the position of the Queen and we
always try to bring the Queen to the
center okay the center is very strong he
comes over and then we go over attacking
both rooks and win one of the rooks yes
and what kind of pin is that absolute
pin right very good
exactly that also does the pin as well
okay okay now next position is white to
play and you need to find the fork or
double attack idea here
well think think
think about it a lot of times in chess
your best move is actually you take a
piece from one side of the board move it
to the other side so it's a long-range
kind of move that's why you have to
always look at the entire board because
you're good the good move you have might
be on the other side of the board here
this one is kind of easy I think you
should be able to find it quickly okay
quick okay let's give some time to
everyone to find it okay let's see okay
all right yes where do you move the
Queen now to attack these two pieces
right black only has two pieces so you
need to find a move to attack this piece
and this piece go ahead very good Queen
h3 a long-range move with the Queen and
now the screen attacks the bishop and
rook double attack is very strong
because in chess it's very difficult to
defend two pieces in one move usually
okay and that's why it's a very strong
idea it's a long-range move you take the
piece on one side you move it to the
other and then you win a piece yes
the pond here yeah otherwise you could
have checked yeah that's why yeah that's
why it's very important otherwise you
would check and gain a tempo and then it
wouldn't don't work but here it's a long
range double attack let's do one more
one more like this okay wine to play and
find the double attack this is a little
bit more difficult okay this is a bit
difficult so you need to you can't do it
right away you need to actually think
about it first think about it first and
find the idea yeah just just just raise
your hand just raise your hand that's
good let's see this is the little bit
more difficult one but okay that's very
good i we see a lot of hands here okay
great yes in the back yeah you move the
Queen where which direction okay which
way you go straight or diagonally uh-huh
diagonally okay this way or this way so
you go here okay check so that's h5 okay
always remember that the last the last
file is H okay from this side of the
board so you go Queen e-track check
that's excellent now he has to go here
and what do you do do you see the follow
up now
okay that's good that's good you find
the first one that's good you find the
first move that's that's important okay
but normally in your games you have to
find both moves okay before you make it
now what would be the next move here yes
go ahead
excellent
see it's the Queen was already on the D
file but we couldn't reach that square
because the pawn was blocking us so we
had to bypass that by going check and
then go here and this way now we are
attacking the knight and the rope and
that is and the pond and and there is
something else what else we have
absolute pain right we learned that that
this is an absolute pin okay okay very
good okay good job everyone we did two
games of Bobby Fischer and a lot of
double attack ideas today okay so next
week will be a different topic that I
will be here teaching okay so see you
next week
you